il a longtemps présenté les JT sur une
chaîne info avant de quitter le
journaliste pour s'engager en politique
mon invité siège aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée sous les couleurs du
rassemblement national
[Musique]
bonjour Philippe Balard bonjour look 27
avril 2021 vous avez posté un message
sur Twitter en fin de journée qui a
provoqué une sorte de mini séisme au
sein du groupe TF1 on va voir ce message
c'est avec un immense honneur que je
serai tête de liste du rassemblement
national à Paris pour les régionales
aucun de vos collègues à LCI la chaîne
info de TF1 ne se doutait de cela ça
ressemble presque à un coming out ça
veut dire que je faisais bien mon
travail puisque personne n'avait décelé
quoi que ce soit quand je faisais ce que
vous faites actuellement c'est à dire je
posais des questions
normalement n'a pas affiché ces opinions
quand il est à l'antenne ou quand alors
il écrit là c'est on rentre dans un
autre débat il a pris opinion c'est tout
à fait autre chose voilà et j'ai décidé
alors ça c'est pas fait en un jour mais
c'est une réflexion qui a mûri pendant
des années je me suis dit un jour si je
peux apporter ma petite pierre édifice
pour le combat le combat des patriotes
des souverainistes et des nationaux bien
je vais le faire voilà et pour
aujourd'hui quand même sur cette
découverte pour vos collègues qui l'ont
dit après dans la presse que ils
savaient pas du tout que vous étiez
eren
quand on est journaliste télé voté RN
c'est plus difficile à assumer que si on
vote à gauche ou que si on vote LR les
républicains je pense c'est pas lié
forcément à la rédaction à laquelle
j'appartenais à cette époque là c'est
globalement
je vote terrennes à chaque élection et
qu'on est journaliste dans le service
public dans une chaîne privée que ce
soit radio télé je pense que oui ça
passe plutôt plutôt mal et je pense
qu'on a une chance de se faire mettre un
petit peu de côté gentiment mais
fermement j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête sur
la réaction qui a eu Jordan Bardella
quand vous avez fait cette annonce parce
que ça montre à mes yeux que votre
candidature avait une valeur symbolique
forte pour le rassemblement national il
a eu ces mots la sphère médiatique était
l'une des dernières digues d'où on
attendait pas notre mouvement preuve que
là aussi l'image que nous avons est en
train d'évoluer de manière significative
ça donne un peu l'impression que vous
avez été considéré comme une prise de
guerre par le rassemblement national
prise de guerre je pense pas que ce soit
le terme c'est vrai que j'ai souvent
entendu
non mais c'est vrai que dans le milieu
du cinéma dans le milieu du show
business dans le milieu télé
enfin voilà rassemblement national c'est
pas là où on trouve nos plus fervents
supporters donc avoir quelqu'un qui d'un
seul coup venait de ce monde là
signifier quelque chose voilà on
rentrait voilà j'ai amené ce que je vous
disais à ma petite pierre à l'édifice
vous vous voyez comme un élément parmi
d'autres de ce qu'on appelle la
normalisation du rassemblement national
je vis de l'intérieur c'est un parti
normal enfin quand j'entends
normalisation moi des fois je bondis
parce que je vois pas en quoi c'est un
parti qui a été anormal si je peux ce
terme
des diabolisation qui a été engagée par
Marine Le Pen
depuis plus de 10 ans maintenant et
effectivement tout cela
je suis peut-être poser une question que
vous pourriez me poser est-ce que vous
seriez engagés
quand il y avait des sorties parfois un
petit peu malheureuses de de dirigeants
du ce qui était le Front national à
l'heure actuelle alors à l'époque voilà
c'est sûr que ça aurait été même si
c'était des lanceurs d'alerte à l'époque
comme l'ont dit maintenant sur
l'immigration sur la mondialisation etc
etc alors pendant longtemps vous avez
interviewé les hommes et les femmes
politiques vous avez rendu compte de
leurs décisions vous les avez observés
mais vous avez pas été acteur politique
est-ce qu'au fil du temps vous avez
ressenti une forme de frustration c'est
ça qui a déclenché un peu le mot juste
c'est le mot juste frustration parce
qu'en fait
journaliste comme apolitique en fait on
fait un petit peu la même chose c'est à
dire que quand on va reportage on
observe voilà on regarde on écoute et
puis on rencontre et le politique lui il
a une case supplémentaire c'est qu'il
peut proposer des solutions voilà et
c'est ce qui m'a manqué pendant très
longtemps et donc maintenant je peux
proposer des solutions à travers des
propositions de loi que je dépose et que
signe des propositions loi de mes
collègues du groupe pérenne enfin on
agit voilà on est dans l'action et alors
quand un journaliste se lance en
politique il sait que c'est un aller
simple comme on dit c'est à dire qu'il
renonce à son métier de journaliste je
pense que c'était un soulagement voilà
je me suis parce que moi depuis pourquoi
j'ai fait ça en fait parce que très
rapidement moi j'ai vu j'ai observé
voilà mon pays pendant des dizaines
d'années parce que je suis plutôt jeune
quand même comme un toboggan enfin
descendre nous avons dû à mondialisation
heureuse on s'est désindustrialisés on
nous a mis en compétition avec des pays
qui ont pas les mêmes règles fiscales
sociales environnementales ça a été un
carnage enfin la sécurité grandissante
une immigration complètement contrôlée
une identité que l'on perd en engageant
de cette façon quand
Jordan et Marine m'ont demandé de
prendre la tête de liste pour les
régionales
à Paris voilà je me suis lancé ça a été
un soulagement enfin je pouvais dire ce
que je pensais vous avez quand même eu
un engagement politique quand vous étiez
journaliste c'était au niveau local dans
votre ville au Plessis très vise dans
les années 90 vous avez été conseillé
municipal puis adjoint au maire
UDF de l'époque sauf que vous à l'époque
vous avez pas affiché de couleur
politique pourquoi bah c'était au niveau
local je vous le rappeliez mère adjoint
enfin le maire de l'époque avait réussi
à constituer des équipes une équipe
municipale qui était vraiment
transpartisane comme on dit maintenant
donc l'engagement enfin avoir une
couleur politique ne c'était pas
forcément nécessaire est-ce que vous
voyez déjà pour le FN à l'époque oui je
mais j'avoue j'étais tenté aussi à une
époque par le combat que menait Philippe
Seguin Pasqua de Villiers européennes je
crois que c'était dans les années 99 je
me suis toujours situé dans cette dans
cette zone là voilà et j'ai eu cet
engagement alors j'ai eu cet engagement
qui m'a marqué parce qu'en fait la
différence entre un député et puis un
maire ou adjoint mais c'est que là au
moins quand on prend une décision on
peut l'avoir appliqué dans la semaine ou
dans le mois là on vote des lois notre
action on sait que c'est du moyen long
terme faut que les décrets soient
publiées quand enfin bon voilà j'en
passe des meilleurs vous avez aussi été
délégué syndical au sein du groupe TF1
pour la CFTC pendant très longtemps
notamment au moment où elle s'estit a
été menacée de disparition quand elle
n'a pas obtenu son canal de diffusion
sur la sur la TNT ça veut dire vous avez
été élu local vous avez été délégué
syndical ça fait beaucoup d'engagement
vous allez me dire que vous avez aussi
été délégué de classe au collège et
scout
non mais c'est vrai que j'étais
alors dans la vie de la cité comme on
dit et puis pour pour les autres voilà à
quel moment est-ce que vous avez
commencé à vous rapprocher des
responsables du rassemblement national
comment comment les choses se sont
faites en fait c'est naturellement parce
que voilà je recevais moi aussi des
politiques et puis après il y a le Havre
comme on dit après l'émission donc voilà
moi je parlais avec avec Sébastien Chenu
avec Jordan Bardella moi que j'avais la
première émission je le connaissais pas
en juin 2017 après les initiatives je
faisais il y avait un plateau il y avait
4 politiques voilà trois députés plus
lui qui était évidemment encore plus
jeune qu'il allait à l'heure actuelle et
je le rappelle pendant l'émission mais
il les a explosé comme on dit et je me
suis dit pour l'émission ouais mais quel
talent et après on a parlé pendant une
vingtaine de minutes après l'émission et
je me suis en 2017 que vous avez
commencé à vous rapprocher
2013 2014 oui dans cette dans cette zone
là ou en voilà recevant des politiques
on a sympathisé voilà et puis tous ceux
qui nombre de députés que je recevais
qui siège avec moi enfin alors j'ai un
comédie audoul etc etc du jour au
lendemain vous êtes passé d'interviewer
à interview V comment c'est
[Musique]
si l'on en croit les résultats du
baromètre Fiducial odoxac que j'ai sous
les yeux pour 82% des français le thème
de la sécurité sera un des thèmes
majeurs ce qu'il y a d'intéressant dans
cette étude bien vous le voyez c'est la
place de Marine Le Pen pour 43% des
Français c'est elle qui est la mieux à
même de lutter contre l'insécurité elle
arrive tout simplement premièrement
devant Emmanuel Macron seul Marine Le
Pen à la volonté de rétablir l'ordre en
France et ça quand on regarde les
résultats du sondage les Français l'ont
bien compris
et c'est pas un léger mélange des genres
dans ce petit exercice est-ce que c'est
pas l'homme politique qui utilise
l'image de l'ancien journaliste pour
faire passer son message politique
je me cachais pas c'était pas Philippe
Balard anonymement c'était non
l'équipe de campagne de Marine Le Pen
donc c'est vrai je m'affichais
clairement puis j'ai essayé d'aller
repérer mais vous jouez pas sur un
double registre quand vous faites ça je
pense pas non non je pense pas non plus
je continue à le faire voilà puis ça me
rappelle effectivement mon ancien métier
si on peut faire passer les idées
communiquer de cette façon autant le
faire en tant que journaliste vous
connaissiez déjà bien l'assemblée est-ce
qu'il y a des choses que vous avez
découvertes une fois député auquel vous
ne vous attendiez pas ah oui deux choses
déjà alors ceux qui pratiquent l'anti
parlementarisme on va leur payer un
stage ils vont venir en stage avec nous
pendant une semaine enfin on travaille
alors c'est pas qu'on travaille trop
attention moi j'ai jamais été de ceux
qui disaient ça alors on travaille
pas forcément d'une façon très efficace
c'est-à-dire il y a une grosse
dispersion je passe sur le 49-3 où on
travaille pour rien mais enfin bon bref
on vit on mange on dort à l'Assemblée
nationale enfin il faut se rendre compte
quand même de ce que c'est pour de
nombreux de nombreux députés donc je
m'attendais pas à trouver ça et surtout
là une nouvelle configuration il faut
être présent dans l'hémicycle chaque
voie chaque voix compte voilà il y a une
présence de changer ça a changé par
rapport au précédentes législatif on va
passer à notre quiz si vous le voulez
bien vous explique le principe je vais
vous proposer un début de phrase et ce
sera vous de la terminer on commence
allez c'est parti quand Louis Boyard a
refusé de me serrer la main
à l'âge j'ai pensé à Nicolas Sarkozy
la phrase qu'elle soit pauvre con je me
suis dit il doit penser ça en fait une
toiser avec le regard je lisais ça dans
son regard c'était vraiment très visible
sur vous je rappelle c'était la première
séance quand il s'agissait délires la
présidente de la souvenir en
l'occurrence et
donc j'ai trouvé ce pathétique je l'ai
plains en fait je me suis pauvre type
les députés pensent que les journalistes
télé
sont très inégaux en matière de savoir
politique si l'on peut dire j'ai entendu
assez souvent mauvais c'est pas mauvais
mais qui manque de compétences voilà qui
sera proximative qui bosse pas trop leur
dossier avant les émissions
et ça effectivement je les constaté
maintenant je suis de l'autre côté de la
barrière je m'en doutais un peu avant
pour te dire être député c'est renoncer
à vous en avez déjà un peu parlé
peut-être oui à beaucoup de choses mais
avec beaucoup de plaisir parce que si on
fait on nous a pas mis on m'a pas mis un
pistolet sur la tempe en disant bon bah
maintenant tu vas te présenter et puis
en espérant que tu sois élu on l'a fait
volontairement pour notre pays parce
qu'on croit on la cause que l'on défend
la souverainiste patriotes et nationale
et pour porter au plus haut nos couleurs
peut-être ils le peinent en 2027 elle
disait merci beaucoup
la politique et moi merci
[Musique]